Consider now the data
that we're going to use.
We're going to have features that
we've computed, these are things like
Bollinger bands and momentum and
price change and things like that.
We're going to use these features to try
and predict prices or price changes.
So this is our X data, and
if we've got multiple features,
we've got multiple dimensions in X.
So this might be X1, X2, X3, and so on.
And this is our Y data,
which we're trying to predict.
In order to evaluate our learning
algorithms in a scientific manner
we need to split this data
into at least two sections.
A training section and
a testing section.
If we trained over the same
data that we tested over,
the results would be suspicious
because we should obviously be able
to do very well if we test over
the same data we trained on.
This procedure of separating testing and
training data from one another
is called out of sample testing.
This is a very important and
essential technique.
We'll call the X data that we use for
training, Xtrain and
the Y data that we use for
training, Ytrain.
Similarly, the data we'll test
on will be split into X and
Y sections, Xtest and Ytest.
So the general idea here is that
we'll take our Xtrain data and
our Ytrain data, run that through
our machine learning algorithm which
might be linear regression or
KNN to generate a model.
We can then test the accuracy
of that model using this data.
So, the input to the model is Xtest,
so we plug that X data into the model,
and out comes something, some kind of Y.
And the question is, is that Y equal to
this Y which we know is ground truth.
The more closely the model
outputs a Y that reflects
this Xtest data,
the more accurate the model is.
Something that I didn't mention,
is that in this class,
our data is time oriented.
So, as you move downward,
we're going forward in time.
We typically split the data
up according to time.
We train our model on older data and
test it on newer data.
It's generally frowned
upon to do the reverse.
You might argue, well this
data's different than that data.
It's still out of sample.
But there are certain look-ahead
biases that can occur
if you were to train on later data and
test on earlier data.